pour atout c'est quelque chose dont je
vous ai publié un homme boxing d'une
langue plus 6 le voilà aujourd'hui il
est central test on y va maintenant
- de plus ça vraiment bien réussi sa
copie cette année avec son one + 6 un
smartphone qui est vraiment très
séduisant ce grand écran de 6,28 pouces
full optique amoled est vraiment
magnifique
là j'ai un mirror black un design qui
est vraiment très très jolie en one + 6
cas des caractéristiques techniques
vraiment très intéressant je veux
partager avec vous mon avis sur ce
smartphone vous dire s'il intéressant
oui ou non est ce qu'il faut l'acheter
est-ce qu'il faut se positionner ce que
one + a vraiment bien réussi ce
smartphone en gros est-ce que ce one + 6
et le smartphone haut de gamme tant
attendu ou alors est-ce que c'est un
produit un petit peu de chez d'as est-ce
qu'il faut y aller oui ou non le
smartphone est vraiment super bien
réussi d'un point de vue esthétique on
va pas se mentir il est super jolie
c'est vraiment une très très belle
réussite de la part douane plus vous
avez ici un écran full optique un mollet
de 6,28 pousse un ratio 19/9 2280 par
1080 pixels une entité pixels de 402
pixels par pouce et vous allez en plus
un gorilla glass 5 à l'avant et à
l'arrière pour un smartphone toujours
plus robuste on a effectivement un
gorilla glass
à l'arrière on a un dos en verre mais
pas de recharge par induction si vous
voulez le recharger il vous faudra
forcément votre chargeur la dass charge
ça c'est quand même ce qui est plus
intéressant pour recharger très
rapidement parce que le système de
recharge rapide n'est pas dans le
smartphone mais est vraiment ici dans
cette espèce de boîtiers de recharge des
charges vous allez lui mettre une
demi-heure recharge et s'avoue leurs
charges et à plus de 60%
c'est bien évidemment une connectique
ici en usb type c en revanche et c'est
parti vous avez effectivement une petite
encoche sur l'eau mais se trouve pas
gênante du tout sinon coche quand même
plus petite que celle de l'iphone disent
donc là c'est pas problématique vous
avez le choix ici soin d'afficher
l'encoche soin de masquer l'encoche si
vous la vasque et vous avez quand même
votre affichage sur le haut mais on voit
bien que l'écran ça être là tous et
encore ce n'est pas absolument aucun
problème bien au contraire la tendance
plutôt à agrandir le smartphone et ça
c'est plutôt bien aussi autre point qui
est vraiment très intéressant et bien
réussi c'est la calibration et l'écran
votre smartphone est calibré sur un mode
par défaut mais vous pouvez le mettre en
srgb en dci p3 en mode adaptatif ou
alors avoir une couleur personnalisée
soit plus chaude soit plus froid ça peut
vous protéger des lumières bleues c'est
quand même pas mal est en tout cas c'est
vraiment bien que plus le propose en
termes de prise en main je trouve que le
smartphone aussi est vraiment bien vous
avez votre capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui est situé directement ici
à l'arrière de l'appareil
le fait qu'ils aient un petit écart avec
le module photo et vite comme les
positionner son doigt directement sur le
module photo comme vous avez un léger
relief on sent tout de suite à quel
moment on arrive sur le capteur photo et
ça évite effectivement qu'on positionne
sont au dessus ça s'est vraiment bien
pensée la pardonne plus le fait que vous
ayez ici votre parleur mono peut poser
problème lorsque vous allez jouer mais
je pense que vous allez tenir comme ça
et vous risquez avec votre main de
bloquer les haut parleurs
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut faire
attention ça veut dire que la prise en
main lors de parties de jeux lors de
sessions gagne ça peut un peu posé
problème c'est très dommage on y tient
comme ça qu on tienne bien dans les
mains et là très clairement le haut
parleur il est bloqué il aurait très
bien pu inverser et mettre le port jack
ici et met le haut parleur mono ici mais
de la même manière vous aurez eu votre
peau de jackie vous posait problème
le mieux aurait été à mon avis
de mettre le port jack en eau y si de ce
côté et le haut parleur mono ici de ce
côté ça c'est un peu un des points de
regret que j'ai sur son smartphone mais
sinon dans l'absolu je trouve vraiment
bien réussi le fait qu'ils sont incurvés
sur les côtés le rend encore plus
élégant il est dans les critères actuels
c'est très grand écran
c'est encore un écran qui occupe la
quasi totalité de la face avant
c'est plutôt une bonne réussite du point
de vue de l'osce il est aussi plutôt
bien réussie vous avez un oxygène os qui
est basé sur un android oreo il ya pas
mal de nouvelles possibilités et
notamment au niveau de la navigation par
exemple vous pouvez personnaliser au
niveau des curseurs d'alert bouton geste
barre d'état et même la police là par
exemple ont un très joli texte du
magicien d'oz et pouvait faire un
changement de police au niveau des
gestes faisait quelque chose qui est
vraiment vraiment très intéressant vous
avez possibilité de faire des gestes
écran éteint vous avez des gestes
paramétrage qu'elle pouvait définir des
actions par exemple là sur mon écran et
ainsi je dessine un v ça m'ouvrira la
lampe torche
on va essayer mon smartphone était un
mâle en porsche est coupée je dessine un
jet et ça s'allume
ça c'est plutôt bien pour l'étendre
ensuite vous venez là et claque au
niveau d'autres barre d'état vous avez
accès à un gestionnaire d'icônes pour
savoir ce que vous voulez afficher la
par exemple ici j'ai l'îcone bluetooth
hop je désactive
hop je n'ai plus envie comme ça je vois
ce que je veux fichiers ici c'est plutôt
pratique pareil au niveau de votre
batterie vous pouvez personnaliser vous
pouvez mettre une barbe batterie un
cercle ou carrément masquer la batterie
pareil au niveau des gestes vous avez la
possibilité de retourner votre appareil
paf
quand vous recevez un appel comme ça il
fera plus de bruit autre point vraiment
très intéressant c'est au niveau des
boutons et de la barre navigation et des
gestes
vous avez une barre de navigation fixe
comment trouves classiquement sur les
android vous pouvez aussi fait un choix
de la masquer ou alors d'avoir des
gestes directement par navigation par
exemple lorsque je navigue directement
dans mon spotify je suis sur un accueil
je vais sur parcourir recherché radio
bibliothèque
lorsque je veux revenir en arrière et
vous ça vous ramène sa radio je me mets
à gauche
hop je sois et sur le haut et hop ça me
fait revenir directement sur l'option
que j'avais choisie avant lorsque je
veux leur utilisation comme un bouton
virtuel je mets au centre je glisse je
sois hip hop et on en parle plus et
lorsque je vais avoir le multitâche je
fais la même chose au centre mais j'ai
zappé un peu plus longtemps hop jazz
s'appuyer et l'âge et la gestion
multitâche pour les gamer dans votre
mode avancé vous avez un mode qui
s'appelle le mode en jeu dans lequel
vous allez avoir pas mal de possibilités
répondre aux appels via les
haut-parleurs bloquer les notifications
lorsque vous avez joué
économiseur de batteries en jeu une
optimisation du réseau
lorsque vous jouez et vous avez pas mal
de différentes options là dessus en
terme de performance vous annonce la
dragonne 845 avec soi si giga de ram
soit 8 gigas de ram 8 gigas de ram c'est
vraiment pour les plus féroces d'entre
vous ce qu'ils veulent vraiment avoir
des expériences de jeu vraiment
puissante pour sa rame pas du giga de
ram vous n'avez pas forcément dans tous
les ordinateurs actuels donc ceux qui
veulent vraiment du giga de ram c'est
les plus énervés il est disponible en 64
giga avec 6 giga de ram en 128 giga ou
en 250 gigas avec 8 gigas de ram
vous avez une batterie de trois mille
trois cent millions perdre leur côté
autonomie vous allez pouvoir utiliser un
à deux jours en fonction de votre
utilisation
forcément si vous êtes très énervé si
vous jouez à fond à fond comme neige au
soleil si maintenant vous êtes cool pour
passer quelques coups de fil quelques
messages faux paradis quelques
informations temps en temps sans trop en
abuser
vous allez voir l'autonomie va durer un
peu plus longtemps vous avez à l'arrière
un double capteur photo 16 mégapixels
plus 20 mégapixels tous les deux avec
une ouverture de f
1.7 le fait d'avoir double capteur à
vous servir notamment pour avoir un
effet boké vous avez aussi une
stabilisation optique directement ici
vous êtes acteur principal qui est de
19% plus grand que celui du one + 5 t
notamment pour la luminosité ça va être
vraiment top
et vous avez aussi une amélioration du
traitement logiciel vous avez différents
modes vidéo photos portraits ralenti
mode pro accéléré et panorama côté vidéo
pouvait filmer bien évidemment en 1080p
en 1080p à 60 images par seconde mais
aussi en 4k et en 4k à 60 images par
seconde bon attention quelques à 60
images par seconde ce qu'on a quand même
beaucoup plus de place si vous voulez
récupérer ces vidéos pour les monter
dans un logiciel vraiment vous imaginez
ce pas suffisamment performante sinon ça
risque vraiment de ramener côté photo
vous avez aussi la possibilité d'avoir
du hdr vous pouvez faire aussi
directement du slow motion là il est
paramétré en 1080p à 240 images par
seconde
vous pouvez passer en 720p à 480 images
par seconde côté photo c'est très
intéressant vous avez aussi un
inclinomètre pour vous donner l'angle
l'inclinaison de votre smartphone pour
être vraiment droit
ça vous fait un petit niveau vous devez
régler si vos iso votre balance des
blancs il ya pas mal de choses et vous
pouvez prendre des photos en mode raw si
vous le souhaitez lorsqu'on passe
exactement sur les caméras avant vos
âneries capteur de 5 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de
2.0 vous avez le hdr le smile capteurs
la gelée réglé sur deux secondes et hop
il fait une photo vous pourrez faire des
vidéos en 1080p à 30 images par seconde
ou en 720p
ici pas de quatre cas en terme de vidéo
je trouve que le smartphone fonctionne
plutôt bien la qualité est au rendez
vous la vidéo est plutôt bien et là je
suis en 1080p à 30 images par seconde je
vous dis augmenté à 60 images par
seconde
et pourquoi pas les moins quatre cas
mais est ce que vont nourrir réellement
besoin
je suis pas convaincu ce qu'on va aller
faire ses cours à l'essai à quelques
plans en extérieur pour voir s'il marche
bien
s'il intéressant on vaut 6 faire des
plans en faible luminosité vraiment en
obscurité pour voir si rendu intéressant
et même des photos voir si les photos
sont bien c'est le rendu est bien est ce
que ce one piece 6 au niveau de la photo
et de la vidéo tient ses promesses
ce qu'on attend maintenant bon ça tombe
bien aujourd'hui la météo est pas
terrible il pleut donc c'est
relativement sombre on va en profiter
pour voir donc là on en extérieur sur le
capteur arrière normalement ça se passe
plutôt pas mal on va faire quelques
vidéos un peu pour voir ces trois trucs
un petit peu bucolique signal l'air bien
kippen nature donc on va regarder si
c'est intéressant il faut que ce que je
vois à l'écran c'est vraiment
extrêmement flatteur par rapport à ce
qui est en réalité fait l'écran aussi un
seul écran amoled qui fait ça les
couleurs sont vraiment très très très
belle et croyez moi que ce que je vois
là du podium le temps qu'il fait
aujourd'hui qui est vraiment pourri
c'est pas tout à fait ça peut calibrer
la luminosité pour être plus clair ou
pour la mettre plus sombre c'est
vraiment au milieu ça va très bien la
chine sur la caméra de celle-ci de ce
que je vois moi l'écran c'est plutôt pas
mal
je trouve que le rendu est vraiment bien
vraiment fidèle mais temps vous me direz
rue ce que vous en pensez en commentaire
par un proche le voyez à l'écran est ce
que vous trouvez que c'est plutôt bien
fait est ce que c'est plutôt pas mal
la chaîne sur le choléra sévit dans un
coin très très très peu de lumière j'ai
un impôt dégueulasse ça c'est malin
hélas le même directement sur la caméra
principale mais alors on va shooter on a
une qualité sur l'écran qui est vraiment
incroyable
à l'extérieur comme je voulais dit le
temps est assez morose il commence à
pleuvoir les couleurs là dessus sont
vraiment éclatante sont beaucoup plus
belle c'est très flatteur limite
sursaturé par rapport à la réalité une
fois de plus et affichage sur l'écran
amoled
à voir en vrai lorsque je fais des
rochers directement sur mon ordi bon eh
ben moi j'ai regardé là je suis en plein
montage de la vidéo
je trouve que la photo est vraiment bien
le rendu est hyper qualitatif il est une
vraie net et qui ce fait il ya des
détails de couleurs reflètent vrai
mon la réalité je trouve que du point de
vue de la photo c'est un bon appareil
photo on reste sur un smartphone on
n'est pas sur un appareil photo
professionnel
mais ce qu'on lui demande c'est de faire
de bons clichés de bonne qualité d'être
réactif et de ce point de vue là
l'appareil photo est très bien que vous
fassiez des photos un peu plus standard
ou alors des photos avec un effet bloqué
un mode portrait de ce point de vue là
il faut que c'est vraiment bien
maintenant sur la vidéo je mets quand
même un bémol
lorsque j'ai shooté et que je regardais
directement sur l'écran
c'était hyper flatteur avec l'écran
amoled maintenant derrière l'ordre
montage je trouve que la qualité est
quand même beaucoup moins bonne c'est
moi que qualitatif
voilà c'est un petit peu en demi-teinte
je trouve qu'il ya une différence entre
d'un côté la qualité de la photo qui est
quand même assez bonne et d'un côté la
qualité vidéo qui est assez moyenne elle
n'est pas mauvaise mais malgré tout à la
symbian et autres points maintenant sur
lequel sur la vidéo je suis un petit peu
un petit peu déçu un petit peu dans
l'antre 2 c'est la qualité audio lorsque
j'ai filmé avec la caméra principale
l'audio est sensiblement correct dès que
je passe en caméra de celle fille tout
de suite jenson qui est extrêmement fort
j'ai absolument rien toucher sur la
vidéo au niveau de l'audio j'ai vraiment
laissé flat et pourtant j'ai une vraie
différence de niveau peut-être que le
micro et vers la face avant c'est pour
ça qu'on lui parlant directement dedans
c'est un tout bon niveau sonore
voilà c'est un petit peu en demi-teinte
bon pour prend la suite bon du point de
vue de lo'jo voyons voir si la qualité
est au rendez vous je voulais dit vous
avez ici le port jack vous avez un haut
parleur mono
on va regarder si c'est bien oui ou non
du point de vue du haut parleur venu
voir déjà ce que ça dit le haut parleur
mono va pas dire franchement super
sucrafor la soudaine une vidéo sur le
web plus voyez le son est super content
maintenant essayer avec le casque voir
ce que ça dit je mets mon bon vieux
casque je branche de dans la mecque
maquis peu à vous le dire si c'est
intéressant oui ou non est ce que le son
est vraiment bien aller
ça crache ça crache très très très fort
c'est ma vidéo sur le hellfest ça marche
super bien
ce soit au niveau du haut parleur mono
vous avez là au niveau de la prise jack
le son est vraiment bon sur ce one + 6
et qu'en est il du tarif de soins de +6
vous pouvez trouver en configuration si
giga + 64 giga de stockage à 519 euros 8
giga +19 8 gigas de stockage à 569 euros
et 8 giga plus 256 giga de stockage à
619 euros
s'il vous intéresse je vous ai mis des
liens en bas dans la description puisque
cette fois-ci one plus ne se contente
pas de le vendre sur son site internet
vous pouvez l'acheter directement chez
amazon c'est d'ailleurs le produit
leader de la catégorie smartphones sur
amazon ya pa très très longtemps
vous n'êtes plus à quel point c'est un
partenariat avec bouygues telecom pour
tous les clients et ceux qui souhaitent
devenir de la marque pour pouvoir
acquérir le one plus en renouvellement
de ce smartphone est il également
disponible sur gears best je vous ai mis
tous les liens en bas dans la
description
au final à qui s'adresse ce one + 6 j'ai
tendance à dire qu'ils s'adressent un
petit peu à tout le monde dès lors qu'on
veut et qu'on peut s'offrir ce
smartphone il conviendra aussi bien au
gamer avec 8 gigas de ram vous avez
temps de revenir en 256 giga de stockage
vous allez pouvoir remettre un petit peu
à l'intérieur et à tous ceux qui
auraient le général veulent avoir un
excellent smartphone haut de gamme à un
prix vraiment réduit il n'est pas à la
hauteur d'un samsung galaxy s 9 plus
soudan whaou étaient d'impro en termes
de photos et de vidéos
mais par contre vous faire plaisir que
voulaient pas dépenser une fortune dans
un smartphone celui là il est vraiment
top
alors est ce que ça vaut le coup
d'acheter ce one + 6 oui clairement
très clairement c'est vraiment une
excellente surprise je m'attendais à
voir un smartphone haut de gamme mais
l'agent smartphone très haut de gamme
je suis vraiment vraiment vraiment
satisfait dites nous ce que vous en
pensez en commentaire est ce que vous
avez acheté sur une plus si c'est ce que
vous aviez déjà oil +5 en plus 5 t est
ce que vous aviez déjà des produits de
one plus dites moi si vous avez déjà
changé votre smartphone cette année
quels produits vous avez pris et est ce
que celui ci pourrait ou aurait pu vous
plaire vous marquez tout ça d'ici là
portez vous bien je vous embrasse métier
moi tous vos commentaires questions
suggestions directement en bas les
jolies pouces on s'abonne et à très
bientôt je vous embrasse et aime ce
grand écart très bientôt
[Musique]